once again Jerusalem is the scene of a
terror attack the second in as many days
the latest happened in the central
Palestinian neighborhood of silwan yards
from The Old City
[Music]
this CCTV shows the moment that the
attacker behind the yellow car on the
right opens fire on a group of Israelis
two of them were armed and they returned
fire wounding and stopping the attacker
a 13 year old boy
we have two civilians in critical
condition it is a father and a son uh
from what we know the terrorists like I
said is a 13 year old from East
Jerusalem at this time the terrorist
himself is in the hospital he was sent
there by forces after they arrived at
the scene
the government has reinforced the
Israeli military in the West Bank and
put more police onto the streets of
Jerusalem the atmosphere in the city is
tense although the situation has been
worsening for months the violence until
now has largely been outside of
Jerusalem but in the last 24 hours it's
come into the city giving this a new and
very worrying dynamic
the recent violence has revived
unwelcome memories of the dark days have
passed into fathers
Israel is braced for more violence this
government promised us that give us
security just give us our security
that's it thank you how does it feel now
compared to back then I feel bad how do
how do you think that they feel now
compared to the past when you were when
you're in charge does it feel very
similar it's not the same I heard that
will stop I hope so
Israel's prime minister binu and
Netanyahu faces a dilemma now he will be
under International pressure to calm the
situation
whilst having to address extreme
right-wing voices in his cabinet who
will want a tough response to the recent
Palestinian violence
how he decides to play it could have
significant repercussions for the Middle
East
Alistair bunkel Sky News in Jerusalem